Selena Gomez speaks out following the
drama between Kim Kardashian and Kanye
West and Taylor Swift the Kimye Taylor
chaos came to a head Sunday after Kim
took to snapchat to share snippets of a
phone call between Kanye and Taylor
while the rapper was recording his
controversial song famous while Kim
snaps didn't appear to show the full
unedited conversation Taylor did
seemingly give Kanye permission to use
her name in his provocative song shortly
after Taylor hopped on Twitter to defend
herself releasing this lengthy statement
and now it seems she's got backup from
one of her closest friends Selena Gomez
the 23 year old tweeted quote there are
more important things to talk about why
can't people use their voice for
something that matters truth is last
thing we need right now is hate in any
form this industry is so disappointing
yet the most influential smh
meanwhile Katy Perry also chimed in she
tweeted rise above it all along with a
link to purchase her new single rise
clever